Many of you have probably gotten mail
at one point or another telling you the
terms and conditions of
your cell phone contract,
your Internet service or credit card,
uh, that these terms have changed.
Maybe some, some of you have
diligently examine these changes,
but I'm guessing most of you haven't.
Today we're going to look at beneficial
national bank versus Ob Peyton,
uh, 2001 case out of the
southern district of Mississippi,
which will help us figure out whether
and why you might be contractually bound
by these change of terms even
if you've never read them.
We'll also discuss arbitration clauses
and increasingly important element of the
contracts we consumers often sign.
So Ob Peyton,
the defendant bought a home satellite
system in 1995 he paid for that purchase
during his credit,
uh,
using his credit card account
with beneficial national bank,
the cardholder agreement
and disclosure statement,
which accompanied Peyton's credit card
agreement with the bank read in part by
applying for an account or signing
the application or using this account.
You agree to the terms and conditions
contained in this agreement and the terms
and conditions contained
in the application which
you and we agree as part of
this agreement, but it also
included a provision which read,
we may change the terms of this agreement
with respect to both existing balances
and future purchases.
A year later beneficial national bank
sent a notice to Payton and all its other
cardholders advising of changes
to the cardholder agreement.
The notice added an arbitration clause
to the agreement stating any claim,
dispute or controversy,
controversy,
whether in contract toward or otherwise
arising from or relating to this
agreement or the relationships which
result from this agreement including the
validity or enforceability of this
arbitration clause or the entire agreement
shall be resolved upon the election of
you or us by binding arbitration pursuant
to this arbitration provision and
the code of procedure of the National
Arbitration Forum.
In effect at the time the claim is filed.
The notice also provided that cardholders
have the option to notify us before
the aforesaid 30 day period has elapsed
that you do not agree to accept these
changes by writing to us. In the
absence of your giving us such notice,
you will be deemed to consent to
the changes a couple of years later.
Beneficial Bank assigned Peyton's
credit card account to another financial
institution household bank.
The notification of this assignment also
included in arbitration clause like the
beneficial bank,
a modification that was introduced in
1996 in 2001 Peyton sued the bank and the
state court alleging fraudulent
misrepresentations and
other wrongful conduct in
response to the bank's filed a
federal action to compel arbitration.
They argued that Peyton suit in
state court was governed by Arbor,
the arbitration clause and Peyton's
cardholder agreement and so Peyton had no
choice but to resolve his allegations
against the bank through an arbitration
process.
The district court ruled for the banks
agreeing that Peyton would have to bring
his claims against them to arbitration.
Peyton offered three primary arguments
for why the arbitration clause should not
bind him.
First,
he argued that the change of terms
provision in the original agreement only
contemplated changes to existing terms,
not the introduction of entirely new ones,
like an arbitration clause.
Second, he argued that his silence
is mere failure to reject the change.
Terms of the contract did not
constitute acceptance of those terms.
And third,
he claimed that the arbitration clause
did not apply retroactively and that the
wrongful conduct he alleged had taken
place before the addition of the
arbitration clause to the agreement.
The trial judge rejected
all three arguments,
but the second argument is the
one we're going to focus on today.
Peyton relied on a California case long
versus fidelity water systems for the
notion that his failure
to reject the terms, uh,
amounted to acceptance of them at issue.
In that case was an arbitration clause
in a credit card account agreement with
household bank that like the clause
in this case was added to an original
agreement that agree original agreement
reserve the right to change certain
terms.
The arbitration clause similarly permitted
the cardholder to decline the new
terms.
The court in long found quote,
defendant never obtained any affirmative
consent from the plaintiff regarding
incorporation of the arbitration clause
is part of the existing contract.
Rather defendant's required the plaintiff
to take affirmative action if he
wished to reject the incorporation
of the unilateral arbitration clause.
The ninth circuit has held that before
a party to a lawsuit can be ordered to
arbitrate and thus be
deprived of a day in court.
There should be an express
unequivocal agreement to that effect.
But the court relied instead in this
ob Peyton case on a different decision,
a different precedent bank one versus
coats another case out of the southern
district of Mississippi and opinion,
which Tom Lee,
uh, the very same judge as in
this beneficial bank case. Uh,
he had written the opinion that case
emphasize that when determining whether
parties had actually agreed
to arbitrate a dispute,
the court had to look to
federal arbitration law,
which addressed the question with quote
a healthy regard for the federal policy
favoring arbitration.
The intention of the party should be
generously construed as to the issues of
arbitrability of court,
could grant relief to the
party opposing arbitration.
But the standards for doing so were high
when he or she presented well supported
claims that the agreement to arbitrate
resulted from the sort of fraud or
overwhelming economic power that would
provide grounds for the revocation of any
contract.
Applying the principles set out.
In that case,
the court ruled for the banks.
The banks relied on
section four of the FAA,
the Federal Arbitration Act in bringing
their motion to compel arbitration.
This section provides that a party
aggrieved by the alleged failure,
neglect or refusal of another to
arbitrate under a written agreement for
arbitration may petition the
United States District Court,
which save for such agreement would
have jurisdiction for an order directing
such arbitration to proceed in the
manner provided for in such agreement
the Federal Arbitration Act.
The FAA was an acted in 1925 but it wasn't
until the 1990s as in this case that
the arbitration clauses came to be used
widely and contracts between businesses
and consumers.
Can you think of some of the reasons
companies might prefer private arbitration
to contesting allegations in court?
Well,
some possible reasons are that the
arbitration process generally is in public
and the parties involved often by
agreement may not disclose the results.
Arbitration decisions usually aren't
appealable and the process is cheaper for
the company.
There's also the lingering concern that
arbitrators are less likely than jurors
to render a verdict verdicts
favorable to consumers or employees.
There's been a lot of recent focus on
how arbitration agreements also allow
companies to avoid class action lawsuits.
This case gives us a good opportunity
to talk about mandatory rules versus
default rules.
As we've discussed before.
A mandatory rule in contract
law is just what it sounds like.
It's a rule that parties cannot
contract around the UCC notes.
Some mandatory,
it contains some mandatory rules.
Parties cannot contract out of the
requirement of good faith. For instance,
by contrast,
the default rule is a rule that governs
a contract if the parties haven't
specified some thought,
something contrary.
Default rules can be contracted around
and altering rules are the rules that say
that specify the conditions
for contracting around
parties if they explicitly
include an altering rule can deviate
from the default in their own contracts.
With that mine,
think of what the default rule
for acceptances in this case.
Well, to begin with, by default,
silence is not a way to
accept a contractual offer.
Indeed even though an offer
or is master of her offer.
And Ken accordingly in the offer
define the ways it might be accepted.
The rule that offeree silence cannot
operate as acceptance is somewhat
mandatory. I can walk up to
someone on the street and say,
I offered a buy your coat for 10
cents and your silence will operate as
acceptance.
That would allow offers
done reasonably impose on,
on the stranger offerings,
time and attention. And so,
uh,
at common law,
a silence as by default does not operate
as acceptance even if the offer offers,
uh,
tries to make it so.
But as we mentioned in the last class,
restatement 69 does provide for three
exceptions where silence can operate as
acceptance.
Let's review them again.
The first exception isn't
really an exception.
It says if the offeree after having a
reasonable opportunity to reject the offer
takes the benefit offered. There's
an acceptance, but in this instance,
the offerings conduct creates
a contract implied. In fact,
there really is in silence.
The second exception is perverse because
it's seemingly requires the court to
adopt a subjectivist approach
toward offeree intent.
Remember normally contract
log goes by externals.
How would the reasonable observer,
the reasonable listener interpret
the other person's words or conduct,
but section 69 instead says silence can
operate as acceptance if the offer re in
remaining silent intends
to accept the offer,
but how has the court to determine this
intent from externals if the offeree is
silent and inactive.
The third and final exception is closest
to the Peyton case and where most of
the action is.
It says that silence can
operate as acceptance if
previous dealing or something
else makes it reasonable that the offeree
should notify the offer or if he or
she does not intend to
accept the change of terms.
Provision in the initial contract
might call qualify as just this kind of
previous dealings,
but the provision is a bit opaque
or one might even say misleading.
The provision remember says we may
change the terms of this agreement with
respect to both existing
balances and future purchases,
but the parties to any contract may
always change the terms of a contract by
subsequently both agreeing
to modify the contract.
The real effect of these change of terms
clauses seems to be to allow customer
silence to operate as a scent.
After the bank unilaterally sends a
notice of modified terms where this notice
is formerly an offer to
modify the initial contract.
The initial change of terms provision
might be at attacked a bit like Williams
versus Walker Thomas Furniture for not
making clear what exactly turns on the
provision, but that's not the
conclusion of the court. Instead,
the court finds that Peyton silence
operates as acceptance or to put it in
default terminology by default customers
except all modification offers the
default legal consequences are what Simon
and Garfunkel might call the sound of
silence.
And hear silence means acceptance.
Not explicitly rejecting terms
indicates acceptance of them.
But in the long case from
California, we, that we excerpted,
the court did not apply the same default
in that case. It instead required,
uh,
express a scent,
meaning that the default meaning of
silence was rejection of the modification
offer.
So what are the downsides of a,
each of these default rules?
A default of rejection certainly
increases transaction costs,
but a default of acceptance
which the court in Peyton, uh,
applied may also,
uh,
increased unfairness binding consumers.
Two terms which they never
agreed to or even knew about.
Several jurisdictions have past versions
of the uniform consumer credit code.
This is different than the UCC.
It's the you CCC and Section Three Point
Two oh five make silence as acceptance.
The default with regard to
a consumer credit contracts.
Indeed it's language may even go further
than the cases we've discussed here it
says whether or not a change is
authorized by prior agreement,
a creditor may change the terms of an
open end credit account applying to any
balance incurred before or after
the effective date of the change.
This statutory language suggests creditors
can unilaterally modify the contracts
even when there is no express change of
terms provision in the initial credit
agreement or even cancel their
contracts if the consumer's object.
The comment to,
to the uniform provision argues that
in insurmountable difficulties would
confront such creditors where it necessary
for them to obtain from each consumer
his or her signed consent to a change.
In terms because experience indicates
that only a minority of customers take the
trouble to return and express
approval or disapproval of a change.
In terms.
Think of all the mail you get that you
probably think is junk and don't look at
precisely because you're not
expected to look at such male.
You may become bound by its terms.
So what have we learned from this case?
We have learned that in
consumer credit contracts,
unilateral modifications to the contract
often will be accepted by silence.
And we've discussed some pros and cons
about that policy, about that default.
We've learned a bit about
arbitration clauses, and finally,
we've learned that you probably would
be wise to read your mail carefully.